congrats on the movie i thought your
performance was fantastic
i'm sure you're hearing that from
literally everyone who's talking to you
today it must be a nice day
yeah it always feels good thank you
listen i have a lot of questions uh
about this project
um but i am a huge fan of a prophet and
i just want to
sort of start with did you have any idea
when you were making that movie that was
going to turn out to be so special i
knew that the movie would
uh would be a good movie because the
director is a great director
i didn't know if if i if i would be
able to portray malik if i uh you know
if i would be able to give what what my
director wanted for me
but uh that the movie would become such
a hit
no i i didn't expect it i completely get
it uh so jumping into why i get to talk
to you today um
you've worked with kevin before i
believe like 10 years ago on the eagle
and one of the things about kevin is his
history with documentaries he's a unique
filmmaker always looking for the realism
in the moment
can you sort of talk about what he was
like making the eagle
and what he was like making this and if
anything had changed
i mean yeah as you mentioned that his uh
sense of authenticity is always here he
is very sharp
you know he it's important to him that
uh what we do and what we see
is uh authentic and real
and uh and um in the eagle it was it was
quite hard for me because i
i could barely speak english and i had
to
master a dead language which was uh
ancient gaelic
and uh we were up scotland
and uh oh every time you want to share
something strong with your director so
you can uh
just you know jump and you'll have a big
safety net and i felt frustrated because
i couldn't really
i couldn't really have the relationship
i wanted to
because of my uh because i couldn't
really speak english
and this time we made it
we made it i'm like i'm not gonna miss
twice
so yeah and uh the fact that he did
many documentaries and movies
uh makes him the perfect director to
tell the story
and as an actor kevin is a great
director
and he's a great person as well he he
cares for actors he
is always open to conversations and
someday he came to me saying uh the best
idea always wins so i felt
you know relief because the chance you
have when you make movies
uh the luck you have is that you you
have the right to make mistakes
so we should it again and uh
i trust him a hundred percent but
especially in this movie
i knew that as has made a lot of
documentaries
and his uh uh used to to shoot genuine
feelings and and and uh
take genuine uh
reactions from real people i couldn't
rely on my habits
and each time i would try something it
has to be it had to be authentic
and if it was right he would tell okay
that's good
and i would trust him so we can you know
you can't rely on our habits when you
see when you work with a director this
sharp
and that's seen that much real people
so it helps you to go beyond your limits
this had to have been a challenging role
no matter how much you prepared to play
this role
it is really uh it's a very i can only
imagine the
the physicality that went on with this
and the pressure
of portraying someone who is still alive
and make basically delivering something
that he's going to be happy with while
also making a movie
it there was i'm sure a lot of pressure
on you did you ever
sort of feel that when you were making
it uh you know that kind of
like uh the importance of the role yes
of course
i felt that when i read the script
and uh way more when i met uh
when i met with muhammadu i was like
okay i i have a big responsibility
i don't want him to feel bad when he
sees the movie i don't want to
disrespect him i don't want him
to feel uh diminished or or in any ways
and uh i felt that pressure the first
days
and at some point you know you get used
to i'm going to spend 10 years i'm
shooting movies so
i found my way to work but the pressure
came
back uh when we started to shoot the
torture scenes i was like
how can i know what it's like to be
tortured
i can't make it up so i gotta
i i was trying to touch a sort of truth
and the only way to make it was to get a
feel
to get as close as possible to the real
conditions of muhammadu
and i did i tried i asked them to put me
real
to to shackle me for real to turn uh
the cell as cold as possible to spray me
with water so i can be
very very cold to waterboard me to force
feed me and i went on a very drastic
diet
to look like him so i could
you know reach an authentic place
and strangely it's a great experience
for an actor to fast
because uh you don't control your
emotions
they control you and all you have to do
is to follow
to grab them and to let them
fly you to some uh emotional
feels that you never expected i'm sure
people
loved being around you when you were
fasting
i don't think so
no um i do want to talk about though the
i'm not sure the first time you met
muhammadu if it was in cape town
uh when he flew when he went down there
can you talk about what it was like
meeting muhammadu for the first time and
what you took away from
uh just talking to him because his story
is so incredible
yeah of course uh first time i met him
was uh
on skype i was shooting the serpent in
thailand and
i mean i couldn't fly to mauritania
so we we talked on skype and uh
it was such a cool moment i was meeting
someone so cool it was a mix of uh
you know muhammad ali and nelson mandela
it was cracking jokes and at the same
time he's been through a real
very hard i mean a hard experience and
but it was so funny it was funny it was
playing music
asking about my family and i felt like
being with a friend of mine
and uh and when i
asked him questions about about uh about
the torture
uh he's changed he's literally changed
his face became very uh sad he you could
read the trauma on his face
and i felt bad embarrassed so i stopped
and uh i felt my guts
my guts told me at this moment just to
listen to this guy
and to try to catch a spirit and spend
time with him but not asking him
too many questions and we spent time
talking on skype many times and when i
met him for real
in south africa when we hugged
i felt like uh i felt like i was
meeting again with someone of my family
that i haven't seen for
years it was great moving and uh
yeah i learned a lot of things from him
from the way he behaved i have to stop
i'm just going to say again
a fantastic performance and such a great
movie
uh have a fantastic day thank you so
much stephen you too